David Boder: [In English] Chicago, November the 14, 1950. This is reproduction Spool 116B. The interviewee is Edith Zierer. Boder.
David Boder: We have now another young girl.
David Boder: [In German] Wie heißen Sie?
Edith Zierer: Edith Zierer.
David Boder: Edi?
Edith Zierer: Edith.
David Boder: Edith. Und der erste Name?
Edith Zierer: Zierer.
David Boder: Zierer. Schreiben Sie Ihren Namen C...?
Edith Zierer: Nein, Z-I-E...
David Boder: Z...? Schreiben Sie mir das auf. Ihr erster Name ist Edith, nicht wahr?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Aha. Und Sie sind bloß gewöhnt den letzten Namen zuerst zu sagen. Sie sprechen deutsch, nicht wahr?
David Boder: Also, nun Edith, wie alt sind sie?
Edith Zierer: Fünfzehn (15).
David Boder: Fünfzehn (15).
David Boder: [In English] We are starting at the, hm, we are starting at the fifteenth minute of the Spool number 116, an interview with Edith Zierer, age 15, at Bellevue near Paris, a home for displaced children, hm, who are here with a group of teachers, which, hm, hm, removed them from Poland.
David Boder: [In German] Also, also sagen Sie mir, Edith, wo waren Sie wenn der Krieg angefangen hat?
Edith Zierer: Wie der Krieg angefangen ist, da bin ich aus Katowitz nach Schlesien, nicht, nach Krakau und dann mit den Eltern zusammen nach Lemberg.
David Boder: Aha. Sagen Sie mir, wie viel...wie alt waren Sie dann?
Edith Zierer: Neun Jahre.
David Boder: Sie waren neun Jahre alt. Und wer war in Ihrer Familie? Der Vater...
Edith Zierer: Da war der Vater, die Mutter und eine Schwester, eine jüngere Schwester.
David Boder: Eine jüngere Schwester?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie alt war ungefähr Ihr Vater dann?
Edith Zierer: Mein Vater? Damals? Ein und vierzig.
David Boder: Ja, Wissen Sie, wo Ihr Vater ist?
Edith Zierer: Nein.
David Boder: Nein. Und wo die Mutter ist?
Edith Zierer: Nein, auch nicht. Sie sind mit einem Transport in zwei und vierzig (42) nach Dachau.
David Boder: Beide zusammen? Vater und Mutter?
Edith Zierer: Nein, erst der Vater.
David Boder: Aha. Also wollen Sie mir dann die ganze Geschichte erzählen? Was hat passiert, wie Sie sich erinnern, wie die Deutschen nach Katowitz sind gekommen? Nun?
Edith Zierer: Da bin ich...
David Boder: Wie der Krieg angefangen hat.
Edith Zierer: Ja, wie der Krieg angefangen ist, da bin ich mit den Eltern nach Krakau und von Krakau dann nach Lemberg.
David Boder: Warum so schnell? Wie lange waren Sie in Krakau?
Edith Zierer: Zwei Tage.
David Boder: Warum sind Sie nach Krakau gegangen?
Edith Zierer: Warum? Weil Katowitz ist neben der Grenze, neben der deutschen Grenze. Und da sind...es gab viel Militär.
David Boder: Militär? So sind Sie einfach weg gegangen.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Was war Ihres Vaters Beschäftigung?
Edith Zierer: Ein...ein Geschäft hat er gehabt.
David Boder: Was für ein Geschäft?
Edith Zierer: Aus Leder...Leder.
David Boder: Ein Ledergeschäft? Was hat er Leder verkauft oder Ledersachen?
Edith Zierer: Ledersachen. Leder und Teppiche. Das war ein großer Laden.
David Boder: Das war ein großes Geschäft in Katowitz?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun...und von Katowitz sind Sie nach Krakau gegangen?
David Boder: Und was haben Ihre Eltern dort...wie lange waren Sie in Krakau?
Edith Zierer: Zwei Tage.
David Boder: Warum so wenig?
Edith Zierer: Wir sind am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) September weg und dann ist der Krieg ausgebrochen.
David Boder: Oh, Sie sind vor dem Krieg weg gegangen?
Edith Zierer: Ja, ein paar Tage.
David Boder: Nun und danach? Und warum sind Sie in Lemberg bloß ein paar Tage geblieben?
Edith Zierer: Nein, in Lemberg waren wir ein Jahr, ein ganzes Jahr.
David Boder: Und wo waren Sie ein paar Tage?
Edith Zierer: In Krakau.
David Boder: In Krakau waren Sie nur ein paar Tage.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann sind Sie nach Lemberg gegangen?
David Boder: Und in Lemberg waren Sie ein ganzes Jahr.
Edith Zierer: Ein ganzes Jahr.
David Boder: Nun und was hat dort passiert?
Edith Zierer: Dort...es war sehr wenig zu essen, es war an Esswaren eine Not und wir haben sehr schlecht [unverständlich] und wir sind zurück nach Krakau,
David Boder: Nach Krakau.
Edith Zierer: Und unter Stalin, das war unter die Russen, nicht?
David Boder: Oh Lemberg, es war noch...das war noch, wenn die Russen und die Deutschen keinen Krieg gemacht haben?
Edith Zierer: Nein, noch vor dem Krieg.
David Boder: Vor dem Krieg, bevor dem deutschen russischen Krieg.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: So sind Sie vom Lemberg zurück nach Krakau?
David Boder: Nun, war da...
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: . . . mehr zu essen?
Edith Zierer: Da gab es mehr, wir haben da Familie gehabt, die haben uns geholfen, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und dann sind wir...in ein und vierzig (41) ist da...haben sie das Ghetto gemacht in Krakau. Und da sind wir dann weg von Krakau, da sind wir nach Velichka gegangen.
David Boder: Velichka?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Ist das der selbe Platz, wo Fräulein Küchler war?
Edith Zierer: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Aha, sie sind weg nach Velichka.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und...nun also, was hat dort passiert?
Edith Zierer: Dort waren wir ein ein halb (1 ½ ) Jahr und dann war eine Aussiedlung, eine richtige Aussiedlung und wir sind weg nach Krakau.
David Boder: Ja, was heißt eine Aussiedlung?
Edith Zierer: Eine Aussiedlung, eine gänzliche Aussiedlung, Juden-rein...
David Boder: Also man hat die Stadt Juden rein machen wollen?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und Sie sind nach Krakau weg gegangen allein oder mit einem Transport?
Edith Zierer: Nein, mit den Eltern. Wir waren vierzehn (14) Kilometer von Krakau ungefähr und wir sind zu Fuß gegangen.
David Boder: Oh, Sie sind mit den Eltern zu Fuß gegangen?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Nach Krakau?
Edith Zierer: Nach Krakau.
David Boder: Sie wollten nicht...
Edith Zierer: Auf die arische Seite, aber da war auch schon ein Ghetto.
David Boder: In Krakau war ein Ghetto, haben Sie...
Edith Zierer: In Krakau war ein Ghetto.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Aber wir sind auf die arische Seite gegangen.
David Boder: Hat man Sie rein gelassen auf die arische Seite?
Edith Zierer: Wir haben arische Aufenthaltspapiere [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband]...wir haben arische Papiere gehabt.
David Boder: Sie haben arische Papiere gehabt?
Edith Zierer: Die Mutter hat arische Papiere gehabt.
David Boder: Oh und Sie?
Edith Zierer: Wir waren noch sehr klein, die haben wir nicht gebraucht.
David Boder: Und der Vater?
Edith Zierer: Der Vater war versteckt, weil er hatte ein semitisches Aussehen hat, da musste er sich verstecken.
David Boder: Was für ein Aussehen?
Edith Zierer: Sehr, sehr semitisch...
David Boder: Semitisch, jüdisch, er hat jüdisch ausgesehen.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: So hat er sich versteckt?
David Boder: Und die Mutter mit den Kindern hat es riskiert...
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: . . . rüber zu gehen...auf die arische Seite.
David Boder: Nun was ist dann passiert?
Edith Zierer: Und dann waren wir...wir waren ein paar Tage in Krakau auf der arischen Seite und dann hat jemand die Mama, hm,...raus gegeben, nicht. Ein Deutscher, hat es, hat es erzählt, er hat sie gekannt...
David Boder: Er hat sie denunziert, ja?
Edith Zierer: Ja. Er hat sie denunziert und hat sie heraus gegeben und sie war auf der Polizei, bei der Gestapo.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie geblieben?
Edith Zierer: Wir sind in der Stadt geblieben...mit meiner Schwester, ganz allein ohne...
David Boder: Das heißt sie zwei Kinder?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und Du warst neun (9) Jahre alt und...
Edith Zierer: Ich war damals schon zehn (10.)
David Boder: Zehn (10) Jahre alt. Und die Schwester war wie alt?
Edith Zierer: Acht (8).
David Boder: Und man hat Euch die Mutter weg genommen...ohne Euch?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Wie ist das...wie ist das gekommen?
Edith Zierer: Weil wir sind zu Hause geblieben und die Mama ist runter gegangen und...
David Boder: Sie wurde auf der Strasse...
Edith Zierer: Ja, und sie ist nicht mehr zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Und Ihre Mama ist damals nicht mehr zurück gekommen?
Edith Zierer: Nein.
David Boder: Haben Sie gewusst was ihr passiert ist?
Edith Zierer: Nein, wir wussten gar nichts.
David Boder: Haben Sie das nachher erfahren?
Edith Zierer: Ja, vier (4) Wochen später haben wir erfahren, dass man sie auf der [unverständlich] Polizei gewesen ist. Das war ein Gefängnis, ein deutsches Gefängnis.
David Boder: Ja und dann?
Edith Zierer: Und dann sind wir alleine aufs Ghetto, weil wir haben keinen anderen Ausweg gehabt.
David Boder: Was heißt das? Die zwei (2) Kinder?
Edith Zierer: Ja. Und im Ghetto haben wir dann den Vater gesehen und zusammen mit ihm sind wir nach [unverständlich], denn in Krakau war schon die Aussiedlung und wir sind weg.
David Boder: Also sie sagten, ihr Vater hatte sich versteckt.
Edith Zierer: Ja, aber er ist dann zurück gegangen in das Ghetto, weil er konnte dort nicht lange bleiben.
David Boder: Wo er sich versteckt hat?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und er ist ins Ghetto zurück gegangen?
David Boder: Und Sie haben den Vater gefunden?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie ihn gefunden? [lacht etwas]
Edith Zierer: Auf der Strasse. [lacht] Das Ghetto war sehr klein, es hatte nur ein paar Strassen, nicht!
David Boder: Sie haben nicht gewusst, dass Ihr Vater dort war?
Edith Zierer: Nein, das habe ich nicht gedacht.
David Boder: Wie war das? Sie sind auf der Strasse rauf gegangen und...
Edith Zierer: Nein, ich bin in das Ghetto gekommen und an der Ecke steht der Vater.
David Boder: Nun, was hat er gesagt?
Edith Zierer: Er hat sich sehr gefreut, aber wenn er gehört hat, die Mama ist weg, dann war das schon [unverständlich; spricht sehr leise]
David Boder: Nun? Und dann waren Sie mit dem Vater im Ghetto. Und was ist dann passiert?
Edith Zierer: Dann sind wir in ein Lager...nach [unverständlich; klingt wie Beshanow] bei Krakau.
David Boder: Man hat sie dorthin geschickt?
Edith Zierer: Ja. Wir sind alleine in das Lager gegangen, weil das war ein Arbeitslager.
David Boder: Der Vater mit den Kindern?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und was konnten Sie arbeiten?
Edith Zierer: Nein, ich konnte nicht arbeiten. Man wollte mich heraus schmeißen aus dem Lager, weil mit fünfzehn (15) Jahre erst fing man im Lager an zu arbeiten...
David Boder: Nun...
Edith Zierer: . . . und ich konnte noch nicht arbeiten. Da hat man mich raus geschmissen, mich und meine Schwester.
David Boder: Was heißt raus geschmissen?
Edith Zierer: Man hat uns einfach raus geschmissen. Die Deutschen sind herein gekommen und haben Kontrolle gemacht und haben uns raus geschmissen.
David Boder: Sie haben Ihnen gesagt, sie sollen weg gehen?
Edith Zierer: Ja. Aber sie haben es nicht gesagt, sie haben uns über den Drahtzaun geschmissen.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen, man hat sie aufgehoben und rausgeworfen?
Edith Zierer: Ja. Das waren solche Drahte und da hat man uns raus geschmissen. Der Vater war nicht da, der war bei der Arbeit und wir waren allein im Lager.
David Boder: Aha. Und die Schwester auch?
Edith Zierer: Auch. Und wir sind dann zu einem Polen gegangen.
David Boder: Nach Polen?
Edith Zierer: Zu einem Polen, zu einem Bauern.
David Boder: Sie sind zu einem Bauern gegangen. Und dann?
Edith Zierer: Ja. Und dort waren wir einige Zeit. Und ich...sie wollte etwas bezahlt haben. Und da ist die Schwester geblieben und ich bin nach Krakau ins Ghetto und hab von dort etwas Geld gebracht, habe bezahlt für die Schwester...
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und ich bin im Ghetto geblieben, weil...ich habe dort etwas gearbeitet, ich habe geholfen und habe von dem gelebt. Ich habe dort etwas geholfen.
David Boder: Aha. Der Vater war noch immer im Ghetto.
Edith Zierer: Im Lager.
David Boder: Im Lager. Und Sie sind nach dem Lager zurück gegangen? Oh, Sie haben im Ghetto gelebt?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und dem Papa geholfen.
David Boder: Und was ist aus Ihrer Schwester geworden?
Edith Zierer: Von meiner Schwester? Die war dort bei dem Bauern. Und dann war eine Aussiedlung aus dem Lager in ein großes Konzentrationslager, da bin ich mit dem Papa und man hat die Schwester geholt. Der Papa hat gemeint, dass wir sollen alle zusammen sein.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Edith Zierer: So sind wir alle zusammen in das Konzentrationslager in Plaszow, das war ein großes Lager.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und dort war ich fünf (5) Wochen. Und nach fünf Wochen hat man mich ganz alleine genommen nach Skarzysko, eine Munitionsfabrik.
David Boder: Wie alt warst Du dann?
Edith Zierer: Elf (11) Jahre—das zwölfte (12.)Jahr.
David Boder: Elf (11) Jahre. Also, nun, also Du bist nach...
Edith Zierer: Nach Skarzysko.
David Boder: Pla...
Edith Zierer: Plaszow. Nach Plaszow.
David Boder: Also Du bist nach Plaszow gegangen.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Bist Du mit dem Vater gegangen...
Edith Zierer: Ja, ja.
David Boder: . . . und der Schwester?
Edith Zierer: Zusammen, ja, ja.
David Boder: Hat man das erlaubt, die Männer mit den Kindern in einem...
Edith Zierer: Nein, das war ein extra Lager, aber wir haben sich gesehen jeden Tag.
David Boder: Es war ein extra Lager.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun sag mir mal, wie Du im Lager warst...
David Boder: . . . hm, waren da andere viele Kinder?
Edith Zierer: Das waren...es war ein Kinderheim da, aber ich...ich wollte dort nicht sein, weil ich wollte arbeiten und dem Papa helfen, weil der Papa war sehr schwach. Er hat sich schlecht gefühlt, nicht.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Edith Zierer: Und die Schwester war in einem Kinderheim und ich bin nicht in dem Kinderheim gewesen, ich hab gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ein Kinderheim im Lager?
Edith Zierer: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und wer hat das Kinderheim verwaltet?
Edith Zierer: Die Deutschen wussten von dem nicht, aber die Jü...Juden.
David Boder: Was heißt das, die Deutschen wussten nicht, dass da ein Kinderheim war?
Edith Zierer: Ja, sie wussten’s, aber sie haben es erlaubt.
David Boder: Sie haben es erlaubt.
Edith Zierer: Am Anfang.
David Boder: Aha. Und dann hat man Dich allein genommen? Nach wohin?
Edith Zierer: Nach Skarzysko-Kamienna, das war eine Munitionsfabrik.
David Boder: Wieso hat man Dich ge...
Edith Zierer: In der Nacht war eine Selektion und da hat man mich mit genommen. Und ich wollte nicht [unverständlich] dem Vater und [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wo warst Du denn? Nicht im Kinderheim?
Edith Zierer: Nein, ich war nicht. Ich hab gearbeitet.
David Boder: Du warst mit den Frauen?
Edith Zierer: Ja und der Papa hat wo anders gearbeitet und ich wo anders, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und das war in der Naht...in der Nachtschicht.
Edith Zierer: Und da hat man uns mit genommen...
David Boder: Aha.
Edith Zierer: . . . nach Skarzysko.
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie mir, wie seid ihr nach Skarzysko gefahren?
Edith Zierer: Nach Skarzysko? In einem Wagon waren hundert (100) Leute, nicht.
David Boder: Männer und Frauen?
Edith Zierer: Nein, nur Frauen. Die Frauen extra und die Männer extra.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und wir haben...eine Schnitte Brot bekommen, nicht und ein bisschen Wasser und wir sind nach Skarzysko gefahren. Wir wussten nicht, dass wir fahren nach Skarzysko, wir haben gedacht wir gehen nach Auschwitz. Und...
David Boder: Sie haben es nicht...
Edith Zierer: Nein, wir haben gedacht, dass wir fahren nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Haben Sie gewusst was in Auschwitz passiert?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun...
Edith Zierer: Und dann sind wir in Skarzysko...da hat man uns ausgeladen. Da waren neun hundert (900) Leute, nicht. Und da hat man 70 Leute genommen. Da waren drei (3) Werke.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Ein besseres Werk, ein Schlechteres und ein ganz Schlechtes, nicht.
Edith Zierer: Man hat gewusst, dass man da sterben konnte. Da bin ich auf das erste Werk...
David Boder: Auf dem Besten?
Edith Zierer: Ja, auf das Beste bin ich gekommen und da ich deutsch konnte habe ich eine Arbeit bekommen, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und man hat nicht geguckt, dass ich ein Kind bin. Man hat mich an eine Maschine hin gestellt, eine Kiste unter meine Füsse, weil ich war zu klein...
Edith Zierer: . . . und ich hab gearbeitet.
David Boder: Und was hast Du gearbeitet?
Edith Zierer: An Munition.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Hülsen.
David Boder: Und wie haben die sich benommen, wie haben sie sich Dir gegenüber benommen?
Edith Zierer: Zur mir haben sie sich sehr gut ver...benommen, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Weil ich war klein, aber dann ist ein anderer [unverständlich] gekommen, ein guter Mann. Und er hat sich von Anfang an mit mir gut benommen. Aber dann war es jeden Tag schlechter.
David Boder: Was war es? Was hat er getan?
Edith Zierer: Nicht er. Er ist weg gegangen, nicht, und es sind andere Meister auf seinen Platz gekommen. Und es war dann schon sehr schlecht.
David Boder: Weshalb?
Edith Zierer: Ich war hungrig und habe sehr viel gearbeitet. Es war eine enorme...drei malige Höhe...
David Boder: Was?
Edith Zierer: Es war drei Mal dieselbe Arbeit man musste machen.
David Boder: Aha.
Edith Zierer: Und sie haben uns geschlagen...
David Boder: Wer hat Euch geschlagen?
Edith Zierer: Die Deutschen.
David Boder: Ja, wer?
Edith Zierer: Die Meister.
David Boder: Die Meister selbst oder waren dort Capos?
Edith Zierer: Nein, es waren keine Capos.
David Boder: Die Meister selbst haben Euch geschlagen?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun.
Edith Zierer: Und wenn einer Schmelz gemacht hat, nicht...
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: . . . dann hat man bekommen zwanzig (20) mit einem Gummiknüppel.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen: „wenn man Schmelz gemacht“?
Edith Zierer: Schmelz—das ist eine nicht gute Hülse, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Aber wenn sie...da war eine Kontrolle.
Edith Zierer: Eine anddauernde deutsche Kontrolle da. Wenn jemand etwas schlecht gemacht hat, ein...ein Schmelz—das hat geheißen Schmelz—dann hat man ihn damals geschlagen.
David Boder: Mit einem Gummiknüppel?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Edith Zierer: Und dann in drei und vierzig (43) sind wir weg in das dritte (3.) Lager, nein das vierte (4.) Lager schon—nach Czestochowa. In Czestochowa waren wir für ein ein halb (1 ½ ) Jahr und dort haben sich die Russen...
David Boder: In Czestochowa waren Sie ein ein halb (1 ½ ) Jahr.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Und dort haben Sie die Russen befreit?
David Boder: Und da warst Du ganz allein?
Edith Zierer: Ganz allein!
David Boder: Hast Du die ganze Zeit, während Du in der anderen Fabrik warst...
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: . . . in der anderen Fabrik warst, hast Du da nichts von dem Vater oder Deiner Schwester gehört?
Edith Zierer: Nein, nein, gar nichts.
David Boder: Und Du weißt nicht, wo Deine Schwester jetzt ist?
Edith Zierer: Nein, nichts. Sie ist wahrscheinlich nach Auschwitz und da hat man die Kinder, alle...weg weg gemacht.
David Boder: In Auschwitz hat man die Kinder weg [unverständlich; flüstert]. Nun und dann haben Dich die Russen befreit. Und was ist dann passiert?
Edith Zierer: Da bin ich nach Katowitz zurück, weil ich hab gedacht, dass die Eltern sind da. Aber...
David Boder: Was heißt: „Du bist zurück“? Wie bist Du zurück gekommen?
Edith Zierer: Die Russen waren schon nicht mehr in Czestochowa, da bin ich mit den Russen zusammen nach...
David Boder: Was heißt das „mit den Russen“?
Edith Zierer: Zusammen...mit dem Militär zusammen.
David Boder: Im Zug oder wie?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Im Zug? Haben sie Dich rein gelassen?
David Boder: Und Du bist zurück gegangen? Und wohin?
Edith Zierer: Nach...nach Katowitz.
David Boder: Ja. Und?
Edith Zierer: In Katowitz habe ich niemanden gefunden, nicht. Die Eltern waren gar nicht da. Das Haus war plombiert und ich konnte da zu einer Frau, die hat mich mit genommen nach Krakau...
David Boder: Hm?
Edith Zierer: Die war mit mir.
David Boder: Aha?
Edith Zierer: Die hat mir geholfen.
David Boder: Warum war das Haus plombiert? War das Euer eigenes Haus?
Edith Zierer: Ja, das war unser eigenes Haus. Weil die Deutschen sind weg, haben sie es plombiert.
David Boder: Oh, konntest Du nicht die Plombe aufreißen?
Edith Zierer: Nein, das war...das durfte man nicht.
David Boder: Aber die Russen waren ja schon da.
Edith Zierer: Ja, aber die Russen haben es nicht erlaubt, weil ich noch nicht...weil ich noch keine achtzehn (18) Jahre alt war.
David Boder: Du hast keine achtzehn (18) Jahre gehabt und...?
Edith Zierer: Das habe ich Ihnen gesagt, nicht. Und wenn ich achtzehn (18) Jahre habe, dann bekomme ich die Wohnung zurück. Weil niemand Älterer ist von der Familie über geblieben und ich war angeblich noch zu jung, um meine eigene Wohnung zu haben.
David Boder: Aha. Und niemand anders hat dort geliebt?
Edith Zierer: Es waren dann Russen da, ein Offizier.
David Boder: Aha. Und er ist rein gegangen in die Wohnung.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Hast Du sie gesehen? Waren Deine Sachen dort?
Edith Zierer: Nein.
David Boder: Aha. Sprich hier in diese Richtung.
Edith Zierer: Nein, es war nichts da.
David Boder: Und Du bist zu was für einer Frau gegangen? Einer Jüdin oder ?
Edith Zierer: Eine Jüdin.
David Boder: Und?
Edith Zierer: Die hat mich zu sich genommen und mir ist es sehr gut gegangen bei ihr. Ja.
David Boder: Nun und dann? Sie waren fünf (5) Wochen dort?
Edith Zierer: Und dann hat man mich nach Zakopane geschickt.
David Boder: Wer?
Edith Zierer: Das Kommittee?
David Boder: Was für ein Kommittee war das?
Edith Zierer: Das Kommittee von Katowitz, ein jüdisches Kommittee.
David Boder: Und wie weit ist Zakopane von Katowitz?
Edith Zierer: Von Katowitz? Hundert fünfzig Kilometer.
David Boder: Aha.
Edith Zierer: Das ist ein Kinderheim, nicht. Und da...
David Boder: Ja, Da hat man Dich in ein Kinderheim geschickt, wo...
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: . . . wo Frau Küchler war?
David Boder: Und...was ist da passiert?
Edith Zierer: Da hatte ich es sehr gut und ich habe gelernt und dann sind wir nach Frankreich.
David Boder: Warum seid Ihr weg nach Frankreich? Was hat dort passiert?
Edith Zierer: Es waren...die Polen. Die Polen haben geschlagen, nicht.
David Boder: Wen?
Edith Zierer: Die Juden. Weil wir...wir sind ja in die Schule gegangen—ins Gymnasium—und die haben uns geschlagen und...
David Boder: Wer? Die Kinder in der Schule?
Edith Zierer: Die Kinder in der Schule, ja
David Boder: Warum?
Edith Zierer: Antisemitisch.
David Boder: Na ja, aber...der Krieg war ja...es waren befreit die Polen. Da war...
Edith Zierer: Na, aber sie wollten nicht...in Zakopane da waren sehr viele Religionen und sie wollten keine Juden haben. Sie konnten auf die Juden gar nicht gucken. Und sie...man hat die Juden geschlagen, dass es hat einen besseren Platz gegeben und...
David Boder: Und was haben die Lehrer gesagt? Und die Polizei?
Edith Zierer: Die Lehrer [unverständlich; Rauschen im Tonband]
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Der Direktor hat sich geschrieen ein bisschen...sie angeschrien.
David Boder: Er hat mit ihnen geschimpft ein wenig.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Aber sie haben sich nicht gekümmert.
Edith Zierer: Nein, gar nicht.
David Boder: Nein. Nun und dann in Zakopane, was hat da passiert?
Edith Zierer: So sind wir weg. Diese...die Frau Küchler hat...das heißt wir sind weg gegangen mit ihr.
David Boder: Und wohin sind Sie gefahren?
Edith Zierer: Nach...erst nach Prag . Und von Prag—wir waren eine Woche in Prag—und dann nach Frankreich.
David Boder: Wie sind Sie gefahren nach Frankreich? In einem...
Edith Zierer: Autobus.
David Boder: Mit einem Autobus. Alle sechzig (60) Kinder in einem...
Edith Zierer: Zwei (2) Auto.
David Boder: Zwei Autobussen. Wer hat diese Autobusse gegeben?
Edith Zierer: Das war eine Organisation—ich weiß nicht...
David Boder: Du weißt nicht was für eine Organisation. Nun, was tust Du hier jetzt?
Edith Zierer: Hier? Wir lernen...
David Boder: Was lernst Du?
Edith Zierer: In die zweite Gymnasium Klasse gehe ich.
David Boder: Du gehst zur Schule hier?
Edith Zierer: Nein, wir arbeiten zu Hause. Wir haben einen Professor und eine Lehrerin.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Und wir lernen hebräisch, französisch...
Edith Zierer: Und wir haben gelernt Englisch, aber wir können nicht drei (3) Sprachen auf einmal lernen.
David Boder: Ja und sollte man auch nicht.
Edith Zierer: Ja, also wir lernen die zwei (2) Sprachen, Geographie, Historia und so weiter.
David Boder: . . . und so weiter.
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Arbeitest Du? Hilfst Du mit der Arbeit?
Edith Zierer: Ja, jedes Kind hier hilft bei uns. Jede Woche...hilft ein anderes Kind in der Küche, nicht. Arbeitet in einem Dienst in dem Haus oder im Garten.
David Boder: Und wer passt auf die kleinen Kinder da auf?
Edith Zierer: Auf die Kleinen...zwei (2) Frauen, nicht.
David Boder: Zwei Frauen passen auf die kleinen Kinder auf?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Müsst Ihr damit mit helfen?
Edith Zierer: Nein, jetzt schon nicht.
David Boder: Jetzt schon nicht mehr. Nun und was wird aus Dir werden?
Edith Zierer: Ich weiß es nicht.
David Boder: Oh! Was willst Du lernen? Was möchtest Du studieren? Was möchtest Du lernen?
Edith Zierer: Ich möchte studieren.
David Boder: Ja.
Edith Zierer: Ich weiß aber nicht.
David Boder: Wieviel Schule hast Du gehabt?
Edith Zierer: Schule? Ich habe vier (4) Klassen gelernt, beendet, nicht, nein. Und wenn der Krieg war beendet in Zakopane, die erste Klasse Gymnasium und dann [unverständlich; spricht sehr leise, Geräusch im Tonband]...
David Boder: Nun, denkst Du, willst Du ein Fach lernen?
Edith Zierer: Ein Fach? Nein, ich möchte studieren, ich hab sehr gern Sprachen zu lernen.
David Boder: Ja. Welche Sprachen?
Edith Zierer: Das ist egal.
David Boder: Ja und wohin werdet Ihr alle gehen?
Edith Zierer: Nach Palästina, bestimmt!
David Boder: Ihr werdet bestimmt nach Palästina gehen?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Nun dort werden ja die Meisten auf dem Lande arbeiten.
Edith Zierer: Na ja, vielleicht!
David Boder: Vielleicht. Gefällt es Dir hier?
Edith Zierer: Ja, sehr.
David Boder: Nun ja, kannst Du mir sagen, wenn ich Dich frage, von dieser ganzen Zeit—welcher war der schwerste Moment in Deinem Leben?
Edith Zierer: Der schwerste Moment war damals, wie man hat die Mama weg genommen. Ich bin ganz allein geblieben mit der Schwester, ohne einen Groschen. Kein Geld haben wir gehabt, nicht. Und wir wussten nicht, wo der Vater ist. Wir waren ganz allein auf der arischen Seite. Und dann...wenn ich bin weg ohne die Eltern, ohne den Vater und die Schwester, nach...nach Skarzysko.
David Boder: Hm,...wenn Du in der Munitionsfabrik gearbeitet hast, wo hast Du geschlafen?
Edith Zierer: Es waren lange Baracken für hundert fünfzig (150)...viele Stockbetten...hundert fünfzig (15) Menschen waren in einer langen Baracke da.
David Boder: Die Frauen allein?
Edith Zierer: Ja, extra Frauen, extra Männer.
David Boder: Waren Deine Haare abgeschoren?
Edith Zierer: Ja, nur vom [unverständlich].
David Boder: Aber sonst nicht?
Edith Zierer: Nein.
David Boder: Habt Ihr Euch rein halten können dort?
Edith Zierer: Ja.
David Boder: Hat man Seife gegeben?
Edith Zierer: Sehr wenig. Aber man hat mit Soda in der Munitionsfabrik...ist für Seife und wir haben...dort Soda. Und wir haben sich mit Soda gewaschen. Es hat sehr gebrannt, aber...
David Boder: Ja. Ihr habt Euch mit dem Soda gewaschen. Wozu war die Seife in der Munitionsfabrik?
Edith Zierer: Um zu waschen die Hülsen, man wäscht die Hülsen.
David Boder: Oh, da habt Ihr Seife mit genommen oder was?
Edith Zierer: Nein, man darf sie nicht mit nehmen. Man hat Schläge bekommen für das. Aber man hat manchmal bekommen vom Meister, wenn er gut aufgelegt war.
David Boder: This concludes the interview with Edith Zierer, a fifteen year old young girl, hm, who is now in the home for displaced children at Bellevue near Paris. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.